foreign
is the bruising villainous Boss Of The
Mercenary group Wagner whose forces
recently captured the Ukrainian city of
bakmut he says what he thinks about the
way the war is going and he has slated
the Russian armed forces in a way that
nobody else gets away with
the news
this is the kind of address that we've
got used to seeing from yevgeni
pregozians director camera not mincing
his words a lot of expletives in there
criticizing the top military brass of
the Russian army discrediting the
Russian Armed Forces which most people
go to jail for but yevgeni Prego does
not and basically every time he wants
more ammunition he gets on camera he
screams and then he gets some
foreign
but since he won in bakmut he's become
more popular
this this is an interesting clip this
caused quite a stir because Let's Play
It Again
that would suggest and people thought he
was talking about Vladimir Putin he then
backtracked and said actually I meant
Valerie garasimov the chief of the
general staff the guy who runs things in
Ukraine who he hates almost as much as
he hates the defense minister but this
was a moment where you did wonder
whether Putin might not step in and try
and deal with him but Putin hasn't
figured understands his role in the
Putin system apart from that one slip he
has never criticized Vladimir Putin
directly he's never bitten the hand that
feeds him and everything that he's done
to date his whole business Empire has
been entirely for the kremlin's benefit
for all his bruising manner though he
has proven himself to be quite a leader
of men and he's going around the regions
and talking to the wives and the mothers
who've lost their children their sons
their husbands in his forces in Ukraine
he's done a lot more than Vladimir Putin
has but these are quite tragic scenes
here he is laying a wreath at the grave
of yet another man who's been lost on
the battlefield this woman he's about to
present with a car and so that makes up
for the loss of a loved one but at least
he's doing it and I think that has won
him a degree of support and sympathy and
people do agree with the stuff that he's
saying he says what needs to be said and
what nobody else is saying and here you
can see him with his men mucking in you
know we haven't seen Vladimir Putin in
fatigue he's only in his business suit
back in Moscow I mean he's very good at
carving out a PR image for himself a man
and man a populist which is actually
exactly what Putin tries to be
he really thinks of himself as an
anti-elite but actually he's got the
kind of money that the elites do his
daughter's also sitting abroad having a
lovely time so it's a bit Rich when he
criticizes like the son of Sergey shoigu
and the oligarchs children for being
abroad when his own is too this is quite
interesting now pregozian is going on
this tour of the Russian regions he's
been to various Russian cities
Christians
basically a sort of military patriotic
tour where he talks all about the need
for a further mobilization a
mobilization of the economy he says that
Russia has to get used to the fact that
it will be a bit like North Korea in
term in economic terms if it's going to
pull through what the war needs the
sledgehammer has really come to
represent what Wagner is all about and
it's a particularly nasty brutal symbol
because often in Syria and also in
Ukraine Wagner troops have used
sledgehammers to brutally murder people
who've left their ranks he gives it as a
kind of award to people he's given it to
politicians in Moscow he's even sent a
sledgehammer with blood on it to the
European Parliament and these axes were
given to him on his birthday as a
birthday presence Wagner Master they say
and they're also kind of part of this
Sledgehammer brutalist tradition but
let's just take a moment to think about
what Wagner has done for the Russian
Armed Forces for months it fought around
the city of bakmut a horrific battle in
which tens of thousands of people died
you know so many of the prisoners who
were recruited by uh yegeni prabhajan
have been killed in the outskirts and in
the rubble of Bahamut just take a look
at those pictures it is a city that was
utterly decimated and where so many
people on both sides were killed and the
question is what was it all really for
bakmut is not a strategically
particularly important city but it it's
it has come at such a huge cost the
ability to wave that flag above the
rubble and the Wagner flag as well
just such a tragic symbol of this whole
War